We have a pretty good idea of how climate
change will affect the world, but what about
the people in it?
How will it affect us?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and we’ve
been talking a lot lately about climate change,
and how it’ll affect the world around us.
Like everything, though, there are unexpected
consequences - and according to a new study,
one of the consequences of climate change,
is fewer males being born.
It sounds crazy, but this has actually been
happening over in Japan.
Researchers from the M&K Health Institute
have been examining how extreme weather events
have affected sex ratios of infants in Japan.
Specifically, they looked at temperature fluctuations
brought on by global warming, and compared
them to national data on births and fetal
deaths between 1968 and 2012.
Fetal deaths being any miscarriage that occurs
after 12 weeks of gestation.
And what they found, is that male fetuses
are considerably more vulnerable to extreme
weather, which has led to a decrease in the
amount of male births.
In 2010, Japan experienced their hottest summer
since 1898, when records began.
During that summer, researchers noted an increase
in the number of miscarriages, and nine months
later, they noticed a decrease in the ratio
of male to female babies born in the country.
Meaning the majority of those miscarriages
were male.
But it’s not just the heat that causes this.
The following year, in 2011, Japan also experienced
a particularly brutal winter.
And sure enough, that winter saw an increase
in miscarriages, and a subsequent decrease
in male births, 9 months later.
Researchers say this doesn’t necessarily
mean that climate change is completely to
blame - but it does highlight the fact that
male fetuses in particular, are extremely
sensitive to external stress factors.
Earthquakes, pollution, and even famine - have
all been linked to increased miscarriages,
and a decline in the number of male births.
What’s especially damning about this study,
though, is the exact timing of events.
It pretty clearly indicates that temperature
is at least partially responsible - and unfortunately,
no one’s been able to explain why this is
such a male-specific problem.
What do you guys think?
Any plausible theories you wanna throw out
there?
If so, just leave em in the comments below
- otherwise, thank you guys for watching!